[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue l'émission de débat et d'opinion de
figaro là que je propose de découvrir
tout de suite les quatre thèmes que nous
allons aborder ce soir nous reviendrons
pour commencer sur la catastrophe de
millas cette collusion entre un ter et
un bus scolaire le bilan fait état pour
l'instant de cinq morts le gouvernement
at-il l'attitude qui convient dans cette
catastrophe pourrait-il faire plus
nous en débattrons nous parlerons aussi
des migrants l'europe est plus que
jamais divisés sur ce sujet entre d'un
côté pour faire court berlin bruxelles
et paris qui sont pour imposer des
quotas de réfugiés à tous les pays
d'europe et de l'autre côté les pays
d'europe de l'est qui n'en veulent pas
rentrer il raison ont-ils tort nous en
parlerons nous parlerons aussi d'edouard
philippe le premier ministre qui sans
faire beaucoup de bruit trace son sillon
et se fait de plus en plus remarquée des
français y aurait-il jusqu'à faire de
l'ombre à emmanuel macron nous en
parlerons et puis parleront de dindes et
de ce qui fut un couple mythique de la
vie politique française de françois
hollande et ségolène royal
on les croyait en retrait de la vie
publique et bien pas du tout ils sont là
et ils n'ont pas l'intention de prendre
leur retraite en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils ont déclaré récemment sur
diverses antennes pour parler de ces
quatre sujets j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir ce soir véronique race ou
de bonsoir vous êtes directrice générale
de dentsu consulting observatrice sévère
mais juste des réseaux sociaux
bonsoir guillaume bigot pour soir avait
très heureux de vous recevoir dans cette
émission vous êtes directeur général de
l'ipac business school
vous êtes membre du comité orwell qui
regroupe des personnalités on va dire de
sensibilité souverainiste est votre
dernier livre la trahison des chefs est
paru aux éditions fayard
bonsoir eric decouty pour soir qu'ils
vous êtes directeur délégué de la
rédaction de marianne
votre excellente hebdomadaire mais ce
soit mais cette semaine par don en
couverture le dossier airbus airbus au
bord du crash vous revenu aussi sur les
dangers que la pornographie fait subir à
nos enfants et comment les en protéger
et bonsoir je dis trop grand reporter au
figaro magazine c'est vous judith qui
avait coordonné
le dossier sur le premier bilan de
macron vous avez sorti votre stylo rouge
pour mettre des notes mais pas tout seul
avec des experts tout à fait compétents
au président de la république est
globalement pas du tout mais chacun est
dans son rôle et les journalistes le son
peut ne sont pas des procureurs est pas
toujours des experts dossier intéressant
parce que finalement le premier bilan
est plutôt bon on peut le dire oui
notamment dans le domaine économique et
social
alors donc c'est agnès verdier molinié
qui à la tête de l'ifrap a conçu un
outil qui est en fait une première et
c'est ce qu'il faut dire à nos lecteurs
qui permet d'avoir un instrument
d'analysé rapide quasiment instantanée
puisqu'il s'engage à le faire pour nous
régulièrement avec une note hebdomadaire
dans le figaro.fr à chaque fois qu'une
nouvelle mesure sera produit voilà c'est
le mât chronomètre en main toutes les
semaines sur futures au point d'en faire
autant mais son impact en termes
d'emplois et son impact sur les dépenses
publiques sera mesurée à l'est sur la
croissance merci beaucoup cherchent des
tenues commençons par parler de la
tragédie de millas cette petite commune
des pyrénées orientales où a eu lieu
hier en fin d'après-midi la collision
entre un ter et un bus scolaire faisant
cinq morts au dernier bilan mais il ya
de nombreux blessés
souvent grave c'est jamais facile à
gérer pour le pour un gouvernement ce
type de catastrophe je propose de
réfléchir un petit peu à la façon dont
don
le gouvernement actuel agit dans ce
drame
écoutez elisabeth bornes c'est la
ministre des transports elle était ce
matin sur europe 1 immédiatement une
cellule a été mise en place pour
accompagner les familles puis je vous
annonce qu'on va nommer un coordinateur
interministériel pour aider les familles
pour les accompagner dans la durée parce
qu'il ya l'actualité et ensuite les
familles pourraient craindre de rester
seul et donc le rôle de ce coordinateur
interministériel va être d'être présent
aux côtés des familles dans la durée
pour les aider aussi dans leur démarche
et donc il sera sur place dès demain
voilà et le gouvernement fait-il ac
c'est la question à laquelle nous vous
proposons de répondre sur le hashtag
finir alive hashtag point de vue eric
decouty on a vu tous les ministres
concernés ont pris la parole sur ce
dossier tout le gouvernement a fait état
via des tweets de sa compassion de son
émotion
c'est la réponse qui convient face à une
catastrophe comme celle là je crois
franchement que ce genre de sujet il
faut pas en faire une affaire politique
c'est d'abord une émotion c'est une
catastrophe
c'est un deuil qui nous touche qui
touche en particulier ces familles
évidemment mais qui nous touche tous je
pense que l'essentiel pour le plan
politique c'est la mise en oeuvre des
services de l'état hier que les services
de l'état soit là c'est que le ministre
des transports le musée du cassiot
national est allé sur le terrain aussi
je crois pour pour voir si
l'accompagnement psychologique
et autres services étaient et et opérant
je crois que ça c'est l'essentiel des
catastrophes
il y en a malheureusement régulièrement
et en a 3 ans c'est bien mais que la
mise en cause ou pas du gouvernement ce
plan politique ce serait qu'il ait pas
que c'est ce qu'on fait mais le pour
ceux qui poseraient la question ce
serait indécent
il ya d'ailleurs pas eu de remise en
cause politique et il ya un consensus
tout à fait clair là dessus en revanche
s'il ya parfois et on peut les
comprendre
chez les membres des familles une
souffrance telle que l ont le sentiment
que le gouvernement peut être n'en fait
pas assez écouté le témoignage que donné
ce matin l'oncle d'un des enfants
décédés dans cette catastrophe
il était ce matin au micro de florence
bourg de france bleu roussillon nous
annoncer j'ai fait partie des personnes
vous a accompagné hier après l annonce
du décès y a pas d'autre mot que suscite
annoncé de but en blanc
quant à la télé en fait la difficulté
waintraub quand on me tend ce témoignage
assez bouleversant c'est que le
gouvernement ferait t-il le maximum il
ne peut jamais évidemment compensée
lalana douleur intenable de des familles
bien sûr là on est à chaud et le zares à
faire en plus il y avait un séminaire
qui a permis à cahors qui était pas très
loin qui a permis à edouard philippe de
se rendre immédiatement sur place
son émotion et son émotion sincère était
très perceptible quand il a expliqué que
malheureusement d'identification allait
prendre un petit peu de temps étant
donné
et les ravages causés par causée par le
choc
c'est vraiment effectivement pas du tout
un sujet qui se prêtent à polémique
on verra dans la durée vous rappelez
tous la catastrophe de brétigny-sur-orge
ronde en 2013 une église qui avait qui
avait explosé il y avait eu sept morts
des centaines de blessés
c'est pas mal de temps après que les
familles ont retrouvé un peu de la
sérénité nécessaire pour formuler des
critiques qui se sont avérées pour
certaines d'entre elles parfaitement
fondées sur l'état des voies notamment
est d'ailleurs la sncf avait promis de
d'en tirer des conséquences et des
grands travaux avaient été lancés
là on est à chaud on est dans la douleur
on est dans le drame
je crois vraiment pas qu'on doit
rajouter d'une façon d'ailleurs vous
êtes une majorité 56% à voter à
considérer que le gouvernement en
faisait assez dans cette histoire
guillaume bigot on constate qu'en fait
il ya une demande peut-être nouvelles de
la part des familles peut-être même des
français par rapport aux pouvoirs
publics c'est pas seulement de voir ce
qui s'est passé de prendre d'éventuelles
sanctions de s'assurer que l'anc était
bien en cours mais c'est aussi presque
un accompagnement psychologique
c'est complètement ça c'est à dire qu'on
est dans la politique du care l'état le
girl prendre soin en anglais exactement
on l'état jusque dans les années 80 90
et un état puis il abandonne ses
pouvoirs économiques au marché donc il
devient un état régalien est purement
régalien et puis on dans une troisième
séquence maintenant c'est un état
compassionnel c'est un état pas les gars
tiff c'est une mise en abyme
extraordinaire loin de moi l'idée de
vouloir polémiquer sur ce sujet qui est
tragédie mais la tragédie individuel
n'est pas le sujet d'un gouvernement
gouverner c'est s'inscrire dans la durée
là c'est l'immédiateté
gouverner c'est voir à long terme là on
est vraiment complètement dans le court
terme et gouverner c'est la raison c'est
pas l'émotion et enfin gouverner c'est
ce qui est commun et là c'est pas commun
c'est un accident malheureusement si on
veut revenir sur ce qui est commun là on
peut parler effectivement d'un gel des
investissements publics alors à hauteur
de plusieurs milliards et on peut parler
de la politique de la sncf
qu'est ce que le pilotage de ce
gouvernement 40 millions par an pour le
problème des passages à niveau ce qui
signifie globalement que dans 2000 ans
n'aura fait disparaît des passages à
niveau donc si on considère que les
passages à niveau sont un problème
voilà comment on traite la question
manière là on s'est posés les passages à
niveau et le prennent de la sncf je
trouve que là c'est une espèce de
précipitation ne connaît pas afin
peut-être que vous le savez pas lui mais
les circonstances de l'enquète la
responsabilité 16e je couvre la vous
engager sur un terrain aussi le fait que
je me souviens il ya une espérance bien
aussi d'accord convoquer un sommet
international sur les trois ont la
responsabilité des services de l'état je
pense que c'est aussi une forme de
gouvernance que d'aller sur le terrain
et de vérifier si les services de l'état
fonctionne que ne dirait temps est en
fête et ce serait une de quelles
responsabilités s'il ne se préoccupait
pas de la mise en oeuvre dans ce dans
cette phase cette tragédie des services
de l'état donc je pense que ça fait
partie
pas seulement son plan compassionnel
mais aussi de voir s'il est un
fonctionne bien dans l'accompagnement
des victimes de l'entourage est de
savoir si ça si l'état fonctionne je
pense que ça c'est une mauvaise
polémique nous chercher à faire et puis
d'ailleurs c'est pas c'est pas vous
dîtes du caire du compassionnel
le goût est un peu péjoratif on se
rappelle que jean françois mattei
lorsqu'il était ministre de la santé
avait très chèrement payé payé de sa
place le fait de d'avoir montré une
indifférence en chemisette et pouvant de
l'accalmie de l'été là là on est quand
même dans ça fait des décennies que les
français ont dans l'ensemble l'intérêt
que l'impression que les politiques ne
s'intéressent pas à eux ils ne
s'intéressent pas à leur vie quotidienne
si dans des circonstances pareilles
vous dites c'est pas mon boulot alors là
vraiment vous les perdez complètement et
à juste titre à la question les petits
soins des scènes cf
on n'en sait rien non non c'est rien
ramené d'un gouvernement c'est
s'intéresser aux accidents avant qu'ils
arrivent simplement rien à faire ici
vous connaissez la nativité et la route
dite mais si vous ne connaissez pas la
cause des accidents c'est difficile de
dire que c'est la responsabilité de la
sncf alors nassim ne pose la question la
sncf porte-t-elle une part de
responsabilité notamment sur les
premières se sont pas levés sont pour
l'instant on ne le sait pas cristiano
dit les chauffeurs de bus scolaires sont
ils dignes de confiance bassam en plus
en l'occurrence on ne sait pas véronique
a souhaité ce que les français sur les
réseaux sociaux sont sensibles à cette
implication gouvernementale ou est-ce
que ils sont indifférents différents
forcément déjà c'est un sujet empreint
d'émotion donc vous imaginez bien que il
ya eu énormément de messages pas de
message politique du tout on n'en est
pas du tout à ce sujet-là pas non plus
de messages polémique
évidemment après il ya toujours des gens
qui se posent des questions et qui
lancent des débats plus ou moins étayé
après ce qui était intéressant de
regarder c'est que le cas du monsieur
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure le
l'oncle c'est qu'en fait il ya des tas
de gens qui sont touchés de façon plus
ou moins directe et qui cherchent des
informations des renseignements et
c'était intéressant de voir que parmi
les services de l'état il y à des
numéros on peut appeler on ne les a pas
forcément naturellement faire les
réseaux sociaux ne sont pas qu'un lieu
pour déverser des émotions c'est aussi
un lieu pour trouver des renseignements
des informations concrètes et éviter de
partir dans des choses qui sont un peu
ce déraisonnable que meego qui puisse y
avoir deux phases peut-être les pouvoirs
publics dans un premier temps l'émotion
parce que parce que ils n'ont pas
d'autre réponse
peut-être ensuite dans un deuxième temps
ce travail de fond est ce qu'on est prêt
à investir pour supprimer les passages à
niveau en mettant des tunnels ou des
ponts est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir deux
voiliers un séquençage de l'action
publique ou à votre avis non doit y
avoir que la deuxième partie c'est pas
tout à fait le mont point mon point
était que d'abord il ya peut-être une
disproportion il ya beaucoup de membres
du gouvernement qui sont passés sur ce
sursaut sur le site de ceux de cette
tragédie
mais surtout on peut pas prendre les
français pour des imbéciles sévère sur
des sujets sur lesquels l'état devrait
pouvoir intervenir l'état n'est pas là
et sur des sujets comme ceux là qui
relève aussi d'une logique d'accidents
parce que l'accident et la tragédie
arrivons veulent évacuer en quelque
sorte de la vie malheureusement la vie
mortelle à 100% donc il arrive des
tragédies donc se précipiter et dire que
c'est là c'est la priorité du jour alors
le gouvernement point trop n'en faut ne
fait pas ça non plus ce serait comme de
mauvaise foi de dire qu'il le fait mais
néanmoins c'est une tentation
contemporaine d'aller si vous voulez de
tragédie en tragédie d'événement en
événement d'accidents en accident pour
changer de cap constamment et changer de
priorités constamment ça devient la
priorité jours c'est ça finalement
leleu preuve le sol le seul le seul
souci il y a dans ce phénomène la
radicale d accord avec ce propos parce
que je vois pas la précipitation j'ai en
fait je comprends pas trop ce que vous
voulez dire l'état en fait trop le
gouvernement en fait trop logique de
communication
je pense que il ya la dimension
compassionnel et d'accompagnement me
semble d'une aussi de la politique d'une
bonne politique
qu'est-ce que quel est le procès
oubliant les chapelles et les intérêts
on n'est plus dans une logique de droite
de gauche de souverainisme au soleil que
vous voulez dire quoi que aujourd'hui la
responsabilité politique ce serait
finalement d'être indifférente à cette à
cette souffrance cette douleur là les
gens qui vont sur le terrain parce
qu'ils sont en responsabilité comme un
témoignage et je trouve que je n'ai pas
de sympathie particulière pour les uns
ou les autres
je trouve que ils n'en font pas trop ils
ne sont pas dans une espèce de
communication de de la larme à tout va
je trouve qu'il ya une forme de
responsabilité d'un accompagnement
face à cette tragédie et je trouve que
pour le reste tout la glose qu'on peut
faire autour de sa part elle peut être
fondée à maintenant on a des
informations des informations concrètes
sur les
l'accident sur les responsabilités moi à
mon niveau peut-être que vous en avez on
en a pas donc à partir de là c'est
difficile de faire des exégèses sur
quelque chose dont on ne connaît pas en
tous les cas moi dont on ne connaît pas
les fondements eric de demande s'il ya
ou non récupération politique que là
vous semble te dire comment c'est une
attitude qu une récupération pas propre
à ce gouvernement et ce n'est pas propre
gouverne pas du tout c'est tout dit sur
ce sujet merci je vous propose
maintenant de parler d'un autre thème
qui a occupé hier et aujourd'hui le
dernier conseil européen
c'est la question des migrants vous vous
souvenez peut-être que au moment
d'arriver massif de réfugiés en europe
la commission avait réussi à mettre en
place un système de quotas pour imposer
l'entrée de migrants dans un salon que
dans tous les pays d'europe sauf que
plusieurs pays européens avaient refusé
cette logique de quotas
faut-il la maintenir ou faut-il au
contraire revenir dessus
il ya une une séparation très très très
claire entre on va dire l'europe de
l'ouest qui est plutôt pour les quotas
bruxelles berlin paris et puis les pays
de ce qu'on appelle le groupe devise
garde c'est à dire la pologne la
république tchèque la slovaquie qui eux
s'y sont opposés
on a deux visions de l'europe
différentes véronique les soutes à
travers ce sujet qui touche beaucoup les
gens parce que l'immigration on sait
c'est un problème très clivant vous en
parle beaucoup ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est quand on compare les conversations
sur les réseaux entre l'allemagne
l'angleterre et la france
on en parle de façon beaucoup plus
décomplexée et beaucoup plus clair en
allemagne et en angleterre qu'en france
en france est assez souvent des grands
débats des des prises de bec des prises
de positions assez radical il n'y a pas
tellement de conversation si on regarde
après est ce qu'ils sont pour ou contre
les quotas on va dire qu'il ya une
tendance plutôt sur le court sur les
réseaux sociaux français mais c'est une
tendance et les décodeurs pour arrêter
les quotas pour les quotas pour
l'économie mais après les propos sont
très extrême alors que franchement quand
on regarde sur les réseaux sociaux
anglais ou allemand c'est pas du tout ça
c'est des discussions des arguments des
échanges en particulier sur facebook par
exemple en france sur facebook on en
parle assez peu qui est un lieu des
chances alors que l'on admet que c'est
plutôt l'argent et donc la question à
laquelle vous proposons de répondre sur
le hashtag figaro live #primaires
faut-il arrêter ou non les quotas je lui
donnais je trouve que la séparation en
deux dont vous parliez
alors certes elle existe mais elle est
assez artificielle parce que qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
une fois décrété qu'il y aurait des
quotas et que chaque pays or est à côté
de réfugiés à accueillir et via angela
merkel a décidé unilatéralement d'en
accueillir près d'un million la france a
été très en deçà en terme de
d'engagements tenus on n'a pas du tout
accueilli les gens qu'on avait promis
d'accueillir puis entre les deux vous
avez toutes les sortes d'attitudes
angela merkel elle-même finissant par
reconnaître qu'elle avait trop ouvert
les portes étant à l'origine d'une autre
négociation sur laquelle il y aurait
beaucoup à dire avec la turquie réfugiés
contre pose est forcé de concours argent
donc on est loin d'une situation binaire
ou des pays très accueillant et où les
actes suivrait les paroles généreuse et
où des pays fermerait tout alors des
pays qui ne veulent pas accueillir
il faut leur reconnaître m leurs paroles
en action et c'est bon ils ferment les
portes il y avait aussi la hongrie que
danger ils ont parlé tout à l'heure qui
était au premier plan guillaume bigot il
ya quand même une derrière là derrière
seb ce dossier deux visions de l'europe
c'est d'un côté
est ce que les pays reste souverain et
libre d'accueillir qu'ils veulent ou est
ce que il doit accepter parce qu'ils
font partie de l'union européenne
une contrainte y compris en nombre de
migrants au delà de ça c'est la question
de savoir qui décide de quoi est ce que
ce sont les peuples qui décident est-ce
qu'on reste en démocratie ou est-ce
qu'on est passé dans une poste
démocratie les peuples européens
d'abord le nôtre s'est prononcé
clairement contre la constitution et
haut de la tête constitution il ya une
question référendum de 2005
bien sûr et au delà de ça les sondages
le confirment il ya l'idée si vous
voulez que xala plupart des peuples
européens veulent rester maîtres chez
eux certains peuples de certains
gouvernements souhaitent accueillir des
migrants d'autres pas le fait de
communautariser de rang en fin de de
faire de cette question une question qui
doit être traité à l'échelon européen
et l'argument qui est servi un argument
technique en fait parce que il ya une
nécessité de coordination mais on peut
être d'accord avec la nécessité de
coordination et la coopération entre
pays européens notamment pour surveiller
les frontières contrôler les frontières
etc
au plan maritime et au plan des moyens
de surveillance et on peut aussi être
fermement convaincus du fait que les
nations doivent décider oui ou non
d'accueillir des migrants en réalité
c'est pour faire passer cette idée
c'est l'idée d'un syndic dans une maison
en fait il ya des propriétaires il ya un
syndic
est-ce que d'un seul coup le syndic peut
décider que d'accueillir ou non tous les
gens qui m'ont rentrer dans tous les
appartements de la maison c'est ça
l'idée en fait c'est très simplement ça
l'idée alors pour l'instant vous êtes
une majorité sur twitter à dire non il
ne faut pas arrêter les quotas donc vous
y est plutôt favorable
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en
europe il ya deux syndics si en quelque
sorte il ya le président de la
commission européenne
et il ya aussi le président du conseil
européen le polonais donald tusk et
autant donc une légitimité démocratique
ni l'année alors voilà à donald tusk et
plus tôt pour arrêter les quotas alors
que la commission et jean claude juncker
est tout à fait pour les maintenir
combien introduit au vu guillaume qui
nous dit que finalement l'europe on voit
bien on a bien compris votre propos moi
je pense en revanche que ça illustre
cette affaire là l'échec de l'europe là
pour le coup je pourrais vous rejoindre
au moins sur ce terrain là non pas que
il faille renvoyer l'europe à la
poubelle comme vous semblez le donner
mais c'est en fait l'europe qui est
incapable et là c'est un échec elle est
incapable de se coordonner on voit bien
et je lui dit moi je rejoins ce que vous
dites est effectivement une rupture
entre l'est la hongrie la pologne ceram
et de l'autre côté à l'ouest il ya une
incapacité à trouver à se coordonner
avoir une politique commune et là c'est
le dossier presque le plus caricatural
de l'échec européen en la matière c'est
incapable d'avoir moi je crois à la
différence de vous que l'idée d'avoir
par nation aujourd'hui ça ne peut pas
fonctionner on le voit bien en revanche
qu' une harmonie et une cohérence au
niveau européen à trouver et encore une
fois ce qui se passe ces derniers jours
illustre l'incapacité qu'ont les
européens à trouver une politique
commune
adaptable à l'ensemble du territoire
alors hugo nous dit les quotas sont
l'avenir il faut chaque année définir au
parlement le nombre de personnes pouvant
venir sur notre territoire il faut les
maintenir pour préserver nos emplois et
analyser nos capacités d'accueil g20
troupes ce sujet est d'autant plus fort
qu'eux il a un peu pesé sur la décision
des anglais de quitter l'europe parce
que le break 6 tasses effet aussi sur le
sur l'immigration est-ce que vous aussi
vous opposeriez les les peuples aux
élites pour faire court comme votre
voisin sur ce sujet
ou non non parce que parce que les
élites ou supposés tels sont également
conscientes du rejet que ça provoque le
problème avec la notion de quotas c'est
qu'en fait on parle de choses à ces deux
réalités assez différentes
les quotas pour des gens qui sont des
migrants économiques qui ne sont pas en
situation vital de danger vital
ça fonctionne à peu près bien qu'une
part donc dans les pays où cette
appliquez vous ne pouvez pas appliquer
une politique de quotas au milan c'est
juste impossible
pourquoi parce que vous ne ferez pas
dire on a besoin de 20 ingénieurs en
informatique de quarante ouvriers
spécialisés en textile ça c'est pas
possible
par définition les migrants qui fuient
leur pays ne le font pas en gardant
d'abord s'il y aurait une offre d'emploi
qui accueillirent tout ce qui vient non
pas du tout ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire ce que nicolas sarkozy remontant
est proposé et qui avec avait été
raillée et qu emmanuel macron propose à
son tour mettre des os et hotspot au
plus près des conflits au plus près des
zones dévastées et faire là bas
l'identification de chaque réfugié
d'examiner là bas sur place la demande
et d'ensuite de définir annie à niveau
supportable soutenable d'accueil des
immigrés partis qu'est ce qui est clair
c'est que on voit bien les uns et les
autres organismes proposent des tas de
solutions de ce type là c'est plutôt
paradoxalement les citoyens et la
société civile qui s'est emparée de ce
sujet parce que les politiques sont dans
des discussions point qu'on évoquait et
comme bien souvent ne voyons pas de
solution et voyant eux-mêmes arriver les
migrants il
imagine pas de ne rien faire donc
certains se mettent d'ailleurs hors la
loi mais ils s'organiser sur les réseaux
voit bien qu'il ya des discussions et
des lieux on se donne des rendez-vous on
essaye d'expliquer et puis on propose
des solutions très concrètes qui rejoint
de ces histoires de hotspot est très
précis avec des consignes très précises
des ong
moi j'ai rajouté que j'ai un problème
avec le mot ni gros parce que ça c'est
un grand sac fourre tout et je vous
rejoins c'est un gros problème
en fait il ya les politiques de migrants
fin il ya des émigrés et des immigrés là
on a fait disparaître le vocabulaire est
intéressant on parle plus d'interdît
d'étrangers par exemple part de
l'international
on parle plus de l'immigration des
migrations avec des directions et des
sens on parle de migrants de migration
comme si c'était un phénomène
voyez comme le réchauffement climatique
on n'y peut rien quoi c'est ça l'idée et
les mots sont donc très important en
réalité il ya un chantage absolument
ignobles à l'humanitaire qui se produit
avec des chefs de guerre en libye qui
envoie ton qu'il fonda traite d'êtres
humains
tout ça avec la complicité de l'union
européenne on met tous ces petits mots
ce monde-là sur les bateaux ce sont des
gens absolument désespéré on les pousse
et ensuite on téléphone ne garde côtes
italiens qui les récupèrent et alors
comme la chancelière angela merkel a
besoin parce qu'on patronat lui demande
de main d'oeuvre
allez hop on y fait venir en effet des
coups tirés ce poids en réalité il ya
deux deux phénomènes derrière il ya le
phénomène de certaines économies qui
sont en plein emploi ou vraiment besoin
de livres parce que la question des de
l'immigration n'est pas une question de
morale c'est une question technique on
peut accueillir des gens et on a besoin
peut-être demain dans l'économie
française
quand on sera en plein emploi on aura
besoin de faire venir des immigrants
c'est pas du tout un problème moral et
je pense que la population française de
comprendra très bien quand on sera au
maximum de leurs capacités de production
à partir du monde un chômage énorme et
on a 10 millions de pauvres environ
c'est tout ça paraît complètement fou et
après il ya des gens qui sont en
situation de détresse pour des raisons
humanitaires qui fut des gars qui sont
des réfugiés politiques
et cela on doit évidemment les
accueillir mais c'est parce qu'ils se
produisent ce qui se produit c'est que
des gens voulant quitter leur pays pour
trouver un eldorado et un meilleur
niveau de vie s'entassent sur des
bateaux des trafiquants les pouces et la
commission européenne est complètement
complice avec les tartuffes de
l'humanitaire
ça veut dire qu'il ya des des chefs de
guerre qui met des gens sur des bateaux
avec la complicité de l'union européenne
que ces gens vont mourir parce
quand gala merkel et le patronat dix ont
besoin de main d'oeuvre se trouve c'est
une vision c'est une vision complotiste
qui a monte de mon point de vue mais je
vais peut-être non je viens de passer
deux ans les cris d'un grand complot les
chefs de guerre patrick en coordination
avec l'union européenne et
l'organisation des politiques grand
entre pour c'est pour les besoins de son
film un homme et des réalités
économiques par ailleurs je pense que
balayer comme ça la réalité humanitaire
qui fallait pas en faire un élément
absolument grave pour je trouve que ça
quelque chose d'un peu choquant ce que
vous dites est choquant parce qu'en fait
vous nier les faits le fait que
l'économie allemande ait besoin de bras
c'est un fait c'est pas du tout un
complot et le fait que des gens va c'est
vous qui avez dit que c'étaient les
libyens les chefs de guerre en conflit
encore génération c'était encore
validation c'est bien sûr il s'agit des
mécanismes qu'il était content oui bien
sûr pas le contraire si vous avez les
mollahs fait moins c'est ce que l'on
reprenne complice des criminels
installés en libye ou ailleurs pour avec
le patronat et en gala merkel dans un
objet qui est de répondre aux besoins de
main d'oeuvre
je trouve que c'est enfin je sais pas ce
que ça passera pas comme ça
bon on peut on peut ergoter mais de mon
point de vue ça perd un peu de son
grand-père côté les vieux mais n'ont
sûrement pas et on va demander aux
internautes ce qu'ils en pensent voici
déjà deux points de vue yves qui nous
des sarkozy avait raison il faut une
immigration choisie c'est à nous de
décider
tandis que marc le dis que peut faire
l'onu pour l'interrogation doit elle
intervenir elle me semble bien
impuissante dans ce dossier j'ai les
troupes ce qu'on peut dire c'est que ça
avait divisé jusqu'au pouvoir en place
en france en 2015
manuel valls était contre les quotas et
françois hollande lui était pourrait
finalement s'y était ralliée mais oui
mais ce sont des questions sur
lesquelles les gens ne se détermine pas
en fonction de consignes aux politiques
en ce moment même gérard collomb le
ministre de l'intérieur a décidé de
durcir
un peu il veut arriver à 13% de
reconduites d'immigrés clandestins à la
frontière l'an prochain de 10 de durcir
un peu
la politique de reconduite lors on vous
parle des gens qui sont déjà sur place
eh bien ça a créé un trouble évidemment
à gauche mais aussi au sein d'un match
où on considère que c'est pas du tout la
ligne à tenir donc angela merkel
elle-même ella ella ella a maudit son
point de vue après ces difficultés
électorales
on n'est plus du tout de ces
propositions et on entendait depuis la
france des bons esprits nous dire ne
vous voyez bien qu'on gueule à merkel
avant les élections est toujours aussi
populaire qu'est ce que vous racontez
elle ne paie pas sa politique vis-à-vis
des immigrés mais la réduire à un froid
raisonnement économique notre
démographie est faible en allemagne on a
besoin de main d'oeuvre
donc on va faire venir des gens ça me
paraît être méconnaître totalement une
des dimensions de merkel que tous les
gens qui ont écrit sur elle qui la
fréquentent le raconter sa dimension
sensible au drame humain venant de l'est
et compassionnelle ce qui n'aura pas sa
part de l'allemagne aussi cet e-tron il
exactement
mais c'est pas incompatibles le
compassionnel et l'économique s'articule
plutôt bien merci beaucoup
parlons d'un autre sujet plus léger
celui là edouard philippe le premier
ministre de la république française on a
dit longtemps qu' il était dans l'ombre
des manuels macron qui pouvait pas
exister qui n'avait pas d' espaces et
puis il semblait que les français le
connaissent et l'apprécient même de plus
en plus vers un décret soult nos amis de
l'institut de sondages doxa ont fait un
une enquête pour des dessous consulting
le figaro et france info et monsieur
philippe s'en sortent plutôt bien s'en
sort très bien même son petit point de
faiblesse resterait sans doute sa
notoriété
on va dire un peu de difficulté à être
identifiée mais par contre globalement
quand on le connaît on apprécie plutôt
oui si on prend donc si on analyse un
peu cette popularité il est évidemment
très populaire auprès des sympathisants
dans marche il est aussi auprès des
sympathisants de la droite tordue à fait
sens 1 % un peu moins à gauche quand
même ça reste un homme politique de
droite même si voilà il est dans un
gouvernement dur en même temps ou du et
mais globalement oui bien sûr c'est un
homme politique de droite et qui
appliquent des consignes de droite donc
c'est assez logique les gens de gauche
n'apprécie pas forcément mais quand vous
regardez les chiffres
franchement c'est plutôt positif parce
que 51 % ça va c'est pas on peut pas
dire que ce soit très difficile
oui absolument 40% les sympathisants de
gauche en sont satisfaits après olivier
la presse et près des deux tiers des
sympathisants de des sympathisants de
droite bien sûr parce que globalement
les mesures qu'il prend 1 fonctionne
plutôt bien donc il n'y a pas de raison
enfin là et il a quelque chose
d'intéressant après ce qui est un tout
petit peu plus compliqué au delà de ce
sujet de notoriété c'est qu'en fait on
voit que il est jugé comme étant sérieux
droit quelqu'un de course demeure
intéressant donc je vous interromps une
seconde pour qu'on voie le le
les réponses des français à ces
questions de traits de personnalité on
les a interrogés sur des qualificatifs
effectivement le juge solide dynamique
sympathique compétents dans jetez plus
mais c'est à vous de parler quand même
mais on voit tout est plutôt positif là
on a été regardé c'est qu'après ce qu'on
aime bien faire c'est complété d'une
observation sur des réseaux sociaux est
là en fait on s'aperçoit qu'on parle pas
tant que ça de lui
c'est lié à sa notoriété évidemment et
surtout quand on parle de lui en fait on
ya l'homme est bien juger et la fonction
le premier ministre modibo life il fait
bien le boulot mais c'est quoi le boulot
d'un premier ministre les internautes a
globalement c'est encadré s'organiser
ses coordonnées le travail de tous les
ministres et selon les directives du
président donc en soit finalement on ne
lui impute pas les succès du
gouvernement les mesures du gouvernement
on constate que il fait un boulot de
techniciens il le fait bien
on n'a rien à lui reprocher dessus mais
quand on voit qu'il ya des actualités
spécifique des mesures qui sont prises
on ne lui impute jamais la
responsabilité et la paternité et
l'accomplissement de ce de ces mesures
donc ça va vite agaçant de voir que il
est apprécié mais de façon neutre on
prépare la question que nous posons sur
twitter à laquelle vous pouvez répondre
à chaque figure alive hashtag point de
vue edouard philippe fait tilt de
l'ombre à emmanuel macron la réponse de
véronique révolte et non pas des veaux
eric decouty qu'en pensez vous moi je
pense qu'il est une méthode de
gouvernance très managériale et que pour
le coup edouard philippe correspond
assez bien à ce que nicolas sarkozy ou
claude guéant disait de à propos de
françois fillon c'est à dire que dans
cette pratique managériale ou le patron
c'est le président de la république eh
ben c'est le premier collaborateur c'est
le voilà c'est ça et je trouve et ça
marche et ça fonctionne dans cette fois
ça fonctionne
en tous les cas c'est un une espèce de
couple entrepreneuriat le chef
d'entreprise des gestionnaires en pour
avoir des jugements particulier mais ça
fonctionne et à priori ça semble plaire
je vois ça semble plaire aux français
alors c'est intéressant ce qui a une
bonne réaction d'internautes et l'âne
qui nous dit attention que qu'est ce
qu'on entend par droite parce que c'est
une droite économique est ce que c'est
une droite sur les sujets de
de souveraineté dans un sondage c'est
que les gens vous disent que c'est ainsi
qu'ils se définissent et je me tourne
vers guillaume bigot pour savoir si sur
ce sujet là aussi il a un point de vue
transgressif et un peu peut-être parce
qu'on est on est en minorité avec ma
camarade on est pas on est les seuls
noms journalisme et en majorité des
journaliste moi je pense c'est vraiment
une question de journaliste parce que
vous l'avez dit c'est le collaborateur
le premier ministre est encore plus vrai
depuis le quinquennat on va depuis
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel
le premier ministre est au maximum un
fusible reste un fusible dans le cas du
quinquennat mais fusible plus
quinquennat ou plutôt élection au
suffrage universel plus quinquennat
égale fusible plus collaborateur et je
rejoins complètement cette analyse c'est
un collaborateur et un premier ministre
dont la cote de popularité montrer trop
pour un président en déclinant à mon
avis serait dégagé séance tenant donc
c'est un non sujet et c'est une question
de journaliste un peu et bien comme ça
dans la peau sèche journalistes et fier
de l'être
moi je vois quand même deux éléments
d'explications possibles d'une part
emmanuel macron a été très présent sur
la scène internationale et sur des
sujets internationaux
or on sait très bien que quelle que soit
l'appréciation portée par les français
sur ce que font les chaleurs chefs
d'état à l'étranger même s'ils sont très
contents ça ne rejaillit pas en termes
de popularité
en l'occurrence emmanuel macron remonte
au 6 mai mais peut-être dans une moindre
mesure est en tout cas il n'empêche pas
edouard philippe de monter et puis
deuxième élément il ya une symbiose dans
ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler le couple
exécutif qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
très longtemps selon et ça je pense que
c'était un élément apprécié et à droite
et je pense que ça et je pense que ça
c'est pas une question de journaliste je
pense que les français à son sont
sensibles ils ont eu pendant lé
quinquennat précédent des affrontements
ou sinon des divergences au sein du
couple exécutif
on le sait à l'époque de sarkozy et
fillon on l'a vu à l'époque de françois
hollande et manuel valls
et je pense que ça procédé à participer
en tous les cas à la dégradation de
de l'image de l'exécutif et je pense que
là et je pense que ça préoccupe les
français donc je pense que c'est pas
seulement une question de journaliste
que ce coup là je vous rejoins après on
peut en penser chacun ce qu'on veut mais
que ça fonctionne ya une répartition des
rôles
on a dit au début que au contraire de
votre question c'était le président de
la république qui a les favorites et
totalement le prêt ministre il ya une
répartition à l'international on voit
que leurs rôles sont là et je pense que
en tous les cas là les français voient
un couple exécutif qu'on voue aux
gémonies ou en tous les cas quelle on
prédisait des tiraillements qui
fonctionne et je pense que ça ça
participe aussi de la bienveillance dont
font preuve pour l'instant les français
à l'égard de ce lien avec cette fameuse
petite phrase en particulier
soyez nombreux c'est tout à fait juste
et votre union s'est introduite
intérieur avec internationale est tout à
fait exact
néanmoins je pense que le destin des
deux ailiers et le présupposé un peu de
la question dite de journalistes entre
guillemets c'est que finalement est ce
qu il pourrait s que la malédiction à la
fameuse malédiction matignon pour être
un jour le v est ce qu'un premier
ministre pourrait tirer son épingle du
jeu face à un président de la république
est hélas je pense qu'on est très loin
du compte
parce que je pense que dans les deux cas
même si votre nuancé juste politique
intérieure politique internationale les
deux incarnent bien leur job leurs
fonctions sont bien dans leur fonction
et pour l'instant les français leur font
crédit de bien occuper leurs fonctions
et cette politique c'est celle qu'ils
ont prévu ils l'appliquent ça aussi les
français lors son gré maintenant ils
seront jugés et l'un et l'autre sur les
résultats de cette politique et je pense
pas que leurs destins puisse être
séparés mais l'honnêteté m'oblige à dire
que myriam est d'accord avec guillaume
bigot genre oui ça c'est une question de
journaliste mais c'est pas grave me l'a
souvent regardé cette image qui quittent
des tiers que quelques quelques
heures avant que soit connu le la
tragédie dont nous avons deux millas le
premier ministre est à cahors
donc on a décentralisé sur place le le
gouvernement il ya une image qui est
peut-être celle que celle de kate prises
par paris quand elle voit la province
française alors à gauche c'est un jardin
à la française et à droite il ya des
vaches une espèce de valade de france 2
oui oui est ce que vous trouvez qui sait
parler comme il faut au pays
ce premier ministre edouard philippe il
comble ils comblent une lacune béante
d'emmanuel macro qui n'a jamais été élu
a fortiori qui ne s'est jamais occupé
d'une mairie d'une ville qu'on dit loin
des territoires et qui a eu des contacts
assez rugueux avec avec les élus locaux
d'autant plus qu'il ne leur a annoncé qu
on retrouve neuf que des mauvaises
nouvelles
et l'enseigné pluie était maire du havre
s'est amené lui c'est pas un élu
parisien en plus même si belle macro ne
vient pas de paris à l'origine et il
semblerait que le gouvernement s'oriente
vers une forme de dialogue avec les
collectivités territoriales dans campe
le personnage est le bon et le texte
améliore ya aussi une répartition des
rôles et la parité complémentaires déjà
je résume brièvement n'y a rien qui
traite les français de fainéants et
l'autre qui leur dit je vais vous
apporter la 4g partout avec l'argent
public évidemment il est plus populaire
avant
je vais un peu vite c'est un résumé quoi
bon eh ben je l'assumé cocktail parlons
santé les sites
alors pardon si vous le voulez bien de
françois hollande et ségolène royal on
les croyait
l'un comme l'autre un peu en retrait de
la vie politique et bien pas du tout et
de toute évidence ils ne sont pas partis
à la retraite l'ancien président de la
république 7
expliquer longuement pendant deux heures
sur rtl hier sur ses ambitions son rôle
dans la vie publique et le moins qu'on
puisse dire est qu'il n'a pas
l'intention de se retirer et écouter ce
bref extrait de l'émission rtl
si je fais des observations lorsque l'on
m'a ne déroge est d'ailleurs assez peu
c'est simplement parce que j'estime que
sur un sujet ou sur un autre
je peux apporter un éclairage ou une
contribution
on me retrouvera avant 2022 vous
reportez vous pour déterminer toujours
les choix qu'ils ne paraîtront les
meilleurs et avec le grand respect que
j'accorde au président de la république
à sa politique parce que je considère
que la france doit réussir jeu on dit
que françois hollande est très drôle
entrer la provoquer l'hilarité sur ce
plateau avec sa remarque je fais très
peu de commentaires et regin ont
interrogé c'est trop beau ni eric
decouty on n'interroge pas assez plus
sérieusement je pense que ça traduit une
réalité c'est qu'il a envie de
participer
il a envie il en meurt dans vie
je pourrais presque vous raconter une
anecdote en privé il croise l'autre
joueur un ami dans un cadre privé à un
ami à moi qui est le cas des logements
il parle de sa chienne et il ne peut pas
se faire sans péché de faire une sortie
que tu dis votre chienne et les textiles
et énervé et vidéo vous savez moins que
celle de macron et je pense qu'il a le
profond lui au fond de lui une il est
hanté par cette défaite je pense qu'il a
il est il veut tout sauf se mettre en
retrait de la politique
il a envie de participer au débat et je
pense que il a encore des choses à dire
ségolène royal peut être un impôt le
célèbre article artix et puis il faut
lui donner l'autre on a parlé après de
ben oui on va pas arrêter que ces gens
là parce qu'ils ont été battus c'est là
un autre non plus le droit où la
légitimité pour anticiper au débat
public et mon choisissant bon temps doux
et qui participe ou pas pardon jours
qu'est ce que c'est la légitimité c'est
bien c'est vous c'est bêtement la loi de
l'audience il va faire une deux trois
interventions comme celle là les médias
qui l'aurait invité vous voir si ça
fonctionne que si ça fonctionne pas il
n'aura pas de droit a commenté
l'actualité l'audience sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la visibilité des messages
comment vous dire monsieur n'est pas
beaucoup alors les choses intéressantes
qui après après non on n'en parle pas
beaucoup et quand on en parle c'est
toujours dans sa musique de hollande
machine il adore on adore le moquer et
bien justement valeur rapide à du
figaro.fr nous a rejoint bonsoir
valentin et vous aussi vous scrutez les
réseaux sociaux et vous êtes assez
d'accord avec le diagnostic de véronique
longue bashing c'est pas fini
complètement complètement d'accord le
bashing c'est le mot vraiment
littéralement j'ai posé la question sur
twitter françois hollande et ségolène
royal interviennent t-il trop du moins
font-ils trop de bruit la réponse elle
est clair et sans appel
beaucoup trop nous dit jean sur twitter
en avoir ce tweet on les a mis à la
porte il revienne par la fenêtre europe
libre sur twitter nous dit il ont du mal
à prendre leur retraite
c'est ce que demande de joël d'ailleurs
cet internaute sur lefigaro.fr retraite
et silence voilà ce que monsieur en
l'occurrence françois hollande devrait
faire après cinq ans de désastre pour
les français ils n'y vont pas de main
morte vraiment quand on pose la question
sept autres internautes du figaro.fr
nous dit qui peut encore accorder le
moindre intérêt à la parole de ce
monsieur comme d'habitude pardon il
enchaîne les lapalissades et tente en
vain de justifier son action pendant
cinq ans il est le seul à ne pas
accepter que son passage à la tête de
l'état a été le plus catastrophique que
la république ait connu on a sept autres
internautes du figaro.fr qui nous dit il
ne sait rien faire d'autre que blablater
pourquoi changerait-il sont ans de
présidence n'a été que du temps perdu et
tout le monde sait que le temps perdu ne
se rattrape jamais on terminera avec ce
commentaire de tom toujours sur
figaro.fr
libre à lui de s'exprimer en toute
liberté mais françois hollande a été
tellement mauvais que ses états d'âme et
recommandations qu'il met entre
guillemets n'ont aucune importance
aujourd'hui un mot le holland bashing
sans appel ouais merci pour vous résumer
tout ça il ya les fameux petits et
musique des gens utilisent voilà le plus
utilisé quand on a le mot hollande c'est
un bonhomme qui bouclent heures de rire
guillaume bigot n'a besoin que les
français en veulent encore à françois
hollande
alors peut-être pas généraliser c'est
peut-être les plus productifs qui
répondent à vos questions sur les
réseaux sociaux mais comme si il lui en
voulait de ne pas avoir été le président
qu'ils attendaient je dirais peut-être
qu'il ya une caractéristique de hollande
qu'on peut saisir alors je vais me me
hisser à la hauteur de françois hollande
puisque andré malraux s'était hissé à la
hauteur du jeune d'art qui l'avait dit
jeanne d'arc
c'est la seule figure de gloire qui fut
aussi une figure de pitié et je pense
que françois hollande c'est la seule
figure de pouvoir qui soit aussi une
figure burlesque en réalité voilà vous
pouvez chercher
il n'y a pas d'homme de pouvoir qu'ils
soient des comics en même temps les
comiques troupiers
et c'est vrai que cet homme est quand
même assez drôle il est objectivement
drôle je le dis sans aucune malice sans
aucune méchanceté
alors c'est pas mon genre du tout on
l'aurait fait rire
et quant à quant au couple ségolène
royal et françois hollande
las je pense que ce sont les organes
témoin du monde d'avant en fête
typiquement typiquement il me semble que
on a ciblé les apparatchiks d'un parti
qui joue la démago et qui joue la
proximité et qui s'empare de n'importe
quel sujet pour faire des démagos ce
sont vraiment les organes des témoins
d'un monde politique qui a disparu on
pourrait parler d'autres organes témoin
je me ferai encore plus d'amis mais vous
voyez il ya aussi les dupont et dupond
par exemple t'as vu c'est juppé qui sont
vraiment les la raideur et la morgue et
technocratique qui jouait la démago ça
c'est aussi des figures du passé
on est passé à autre chose il ya eu un
renouvellement de la classe politique
on peut s'en féliciter ou sont accablés
en tout cas ils ne reviendront plus même
s'ils tapent à la porte mais parce que
ségolène royal elle non plus ne n'entend
pas se retirer de la delà du jeu
publique yves thréard dans l'auto que le
figaro lui demandait mais
vous vous retirez de l'action publique
et sa réponse a été brève mais sans
ambiguïté écoutez là je suis libre je
regarde ça que je suis libre je regarde
ce qui se passe et eric decouty vous
croyez qu'elle aussi elle ne rêve que
d'une chose c'est de revenir dans
l'action publique
mais oui mais oui mais bien sûr que oui
mais oui c'est une drogue dure et on
voit bien quand il comme françois fillon
quand ils sont obligés par la force des
choses de se retirer
on sent bien qu'elle ait on peut
retrouver quelques autres exemples c'est
un déchirement c'est un arrachement là
où j'ai dit tu avais raison après la
sanction c'est est ce que on a une
crédibilité est ce que la légitimité en
l'avenir
est-ce qu'on intéresse est ce que on n'a
pas forcément besoin d'être élu est ce
que on peut aussi avoir une parole qui
ont qui existe c'est l'autre il faut
avoir quelque chose à dire il se voir
quelque chose à dire et après sur le
blog il meurt dans vie la disparition
est insupportable lui il est beau
courrier elle a plus d'audience pour
rejoindre on parle plus d'elle et elle
est moins critique et enfin en tout cas
ne fait pas toujours rires sa voix de
ces propos sont repris elle l est pas
opportuniste sur tous les sujets elle
s'est choisi quelques créneaux qui
fonctionne bien donc c'est pas tout à
fait pareil et les en tout cas l'opinion
ne les compare pas tant que ça moi je
récemment une toute petite parenthèse je
crois pas trop à cette idée du monde
d'avant les jeunes et les vieux pour
caricaturer
je crois que sanaa c'est une
construction c'est que vous parlez de
deux questions journalistique si c'est
un peu vide de sens ce qui fait la
différence
emmanuel macron ces distinctions non
mais la question que de l'hospitaliser
que c'est une question jarry se lasser
c'est une question un peu trait à c'est
un propos très artificielle je pense que
ce qui fait la vraie différence qu'on
soit vieux ou jeunes ou du monde ancien
ces deux anciens ou ceux de nouveau
c'est ce qu'on a à dire est que si ses
jambes du monde anciens ont des choses à
dire s'il trouve une légitimité parce
qu'ils sont réélus et bas parce qu'ils
aient qu'ils aient 65 ans ou 35 ans je
pense que ça on s'en fichera
complètement et jeudi 23
elle a quelque chose à dire ce qui va
les essais que ségolène royal a aussi
dit pour expliquer qu'elle ne soit pas
au ps
mon parti c'est la planète alors
évidemment tout le monde vous parlez de
vieilles politiques mais tout le monde a
fait le rapprochement avec xavier
bertrand qui a expliqué que ce parti
claqué la porte des républicains en
disant mon parti ce sont les autres ans
mon parti c'est ma région
donc vous voyez le nouveau monde ou en
tout cas tel que xavier bertrand entend
incarner l'ancien monde
quelqu'un aurait ségolène royal ont
utilisé exactement la même formule 1
maintenant sur lefigaro.fr le dit
incapable de se reconvertir dans la vie
privée j'imagine que dans le secteur
privé
françois hollande ne va rien nous
épargner exécuter ce que françois lancé
à la vie privée se placer hier sur rtl
eric decouty en en sages ayant envie de
donner des conseils forcément
constructif au président de la
république est ce que vous croyez à
cette posture désintéressé là je
répondrai par votre emoji redisant que
voilà mort de rire mais c'est pareil
milan il meurt dormi il meurt dans vie
de 7,2 d'être dans cette position dans
cette posture
le problème c'est que il a plutôt
tendance à faire rire quand il prend
cette posture là c'est qu'il a refusé de
soulever son bilan aux français autant
ségolène royal peut dire gg été battue
parce que les caciques du ps n'ont pas
joué le jeu il va empêcher de gagner
face à sarkozy sur sa beauté va campagne
autant françois hollande s'est lui même
même si les contingences extérieures
étaient très pesant tellurique a dit non
je n'y vais pas ajouter un mot politique
tout de même c'est que finalement ces
deux personnages prétendait faire une
politique ils ne l'ont pas fait et on
pas été jusqu'au bout et en réalité
emmanuel macron fait la politique il
prétendait faire c'est ça le problème on
peut tu pas qu'il soit jeune ou vieux
c'est simplement qu'ils ne proposent
rien baisse est assez bas je les laisse
je leur laisse d'ailleurs ce n'est plus
tout à fait d'actualité mais en fait
c'est ça le problème de fond c'est
qu'ils proposent rien d'autre sur le
marché donc le monde d'avant et le monde
après c'est plutôt que si on n'a rien à
dire on se tait c'est la même politique
on écrit soult vous pensez que les les
internautes pourraient changer d'opinion
sur françois hollande ou est-ce que
ils ont fait défiler ils se sont
définitivement fait leur opinion vous
qui conseille les entreprises pour
améliorer leur image
ça serait ça serait long et compliqué en
tout cas ça prend du temps
recherche barça serait très très cher
non mais c'est surtout il faut des
éléments concrets il faut une histoire à
raconter il faut un point de vue il faut
des éléments il faut sans doute avoir
une logique d'introspection il faut pour
expliquer pourquoi comme enfin voilà en
tout cas où elle a été vraiment en cours
donc on ne change pas d'image comme ça
du jour au lendemain on n'achète pas une
nouvelle image en quelques jours est en
tout cas il faut des éléments très
concrets et là pour le moment il n'y a
pas d'éléments concrets et si je
reprends cette fameuse interview sur rtl
je crois que ce qu'ils ont le plus
retenu est là où ils ont le plus utilisé
le bonhomme qui rigole c'est les cinq
propositions sur notre dame des landes
l'aca unanimité général soit des soucis
aux fraudeurs c'est une bonne idée de
faire des propositions quand on a passé
cinq ans en position pour pouvoir faire
les choses voilà je crois que l'une des
erreurs majeures l'erreur majeure de
dans la stratégie non pas de retour mais
en tous les cas de repositionnement dans
la posture du vieux stage c'est ça c'est
trop vite et trop d'empressement il
aurait fait silence pendant un temps je
n'en sais rien deux ans trois ans en
disant je me recule et à un moment je
reviens et je dis quelque chose de sensé
du coup ça aurait position du saint
honoré aurait du sens je trouve que
cette espèce
quelques mois après et puis on le
sentait bien nous les uns les autres
ce désir ça fait des mois qu'ils brûlent
dans vie de dire un mot qui vous lâchez
les mots à droite à gauche qu'il avait
envie de parler il s'est tenu pendant
six mois c'est déjà une performance je
crois qu'il a il a dû et nous laisseront
leur est le dernier mot à véronique une
autre véronique internautes quitte aussi
sévère avec madame royal que volti avec
monsieur hollande je ne crois pas
beaucoup aux rayonnements de ségolène
royal on lui doit des dossiers mal
abouti qui nous coûtent une fortune
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir un point
de vue dans quelques minutes vous
retrouverez sur figaro live le toque
stratégique avec tatiana jean chercheur
à l'ifri et spécialiste de la russie
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]